مشاهدينا نشير الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
التي هي اوردناها قبل قليل عن عن وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه التي قالت انها فرضت
عقوبات على افراد رؤوس مرتبطين بمجموعه
تقول الخزانه الامريكيه وفق هذه العواجي
ان العقوبات طالت قائده جماعه فاجنر في
ماري فان الاكزان
وتقول ان هذه العقوبات طالت ايضا قاعده
مجموعه فاغنر في مالي ايفان كما قلنا
ايفان
ايضا تتحدث عن ان هذه المجموعه مجموعه
فاجنر زودت قوات الدعم السريع بمضادات
دفاع جوي معنى من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره
محمد العلمي محمد تفاصيل ما اعلنت عنه
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
ربما المثير
للاهتمام في البيان المكتوب الذي اصدرته
وزاره الماليه او الحزينه الامريكيه هو ان
هذه اول مره تقدم على فرض عقوبات لها صله
بالاقتال الدائري في السودان بعد ذلك
ليس له حب مفقود بين واشنطن ومجموعه التي
تتهمها واشنطن بالضلوع في حرب اوكرانيا
وفي الكثير من بؤر التوتر في القاره
الافريقيه وسبق ان فرضت على بعض اعبائها
عقوبات لكن ما هو جديد هذه المره هو
عقوبات لها صله بما يدور في السودان
واتهام المجموعه بتزويد
مجموعه التدخل
السريع بصواريخ مما
يجعل الولايات المتحده نعم
وهذا يعني من وجهه نظر الامريكيه يجعل
هناك اطراف خارجيه لها ضلع مباشر فيما
يجري في السودان وربما
يعقد ايضا المهمه الامريكيه في محاوله
التفاوض او التاثير على الطرفين معا
والتهديد حتى بعقوبات ضدهما بسبب وجود
اطراف هي عديده خارجه
مدى التاثير والنفوذ الامريكيين اذن ما
اعلنت عنه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه هو
عقوبات بحق فاجنر لانها تزود الدعم السريع
بصواريخ ارجوا لكن ليست هنالك عقوبات
مماثله مثلا على اي طرف اخر يزود الجيش
السوداني باي شيء حسب بيان الخزانه
الامريكيه اليس كذلك
بالفعل قد فرضت او تنوي فرض عقوبه في
المستقبل القريب على الاقل بما ايا من
الاطراف الداخليه في السودان او الخارجيه
التي تزود هذا الطرف او ذاك حتى هذه
اللحظه وهذه لاول مره كما اشرت هناك
عقوبات على احد الاطراف بسبب طيلتها
المباشره بالقتال في السودان ولاول مره
ايضا محمد وارجو ان تؤكد ذلك ان يقول
الامريكيون ان السلاح يصل لمن ومن من
بالفعل
لانها فعلا هذه اول مره كما قلت هناك
اجراءات امريكيه عقابيه ضد طرفي القتال في
السودان وبالاشاره بالاسم وبطبيعه السلاح
الذي تتلقاه
قوات التدخل السريع هذا هذا الكلام كيف
يمكن ان يتفاعل داخل موقف او فيما يتعلق
بموقف الاداره الامريكيه مما يجري في
السودان انه ليس له تاثير وان القضيه هنا
هي فقط
لا يبدو ان الامر يتعدى وربما رساله غير
مباشره لقوات التدخل السريع اننا نعرف من
يزودكم بالسلاح لكن عدا ذلك لا يبدو ان
ذلك
يعني
سيتطرف سيتطور الى مضاعفات او تداعيات
مختلفه بحكم ان ربما هذا الموقف يبرز ضعف
الموقف الامريكي وقوته على التاثير فيما
يجري في السودان بحكم وجود اطراف خارجه عن
مدى قوته ونخوله وبالتالي لا يملك الا ان
يفرض عقوبات على هذه الاطراف
وليس يعني من الواضح ان هذه العقوبات
ستؤثر على مجموعه او على مجموعه اخرى التي
تصلح طرفه اخرى في السودان انها ربما
ستتوقف عن مد احد طرفي النزاع في السودان
بالاسلحه فقط لان واشنطن فرضت او تهدد
بفرض عقوباته لكن الموقف الامريكي فيما
يتعلق بما يجري في السودان ما زال عند
نقطه
الحياه بين الطرفين
لا تملك واشنطن عمليا ادوات التاثير
يعني القويه على الطرفين
وحتى تهديدات بالعقوبات لم تؤتي اكلها
وحتى وساطه الولايات المتحده في الهدنه
الاولى والثانيه لم تؤدي الى نتائج وحتى
تهديد بالعقوبات لم يؤدي الى النتائج لان
واشنطن تدرك ان امكانيه تاثيرها على
الاوضاع في السودان متواضعه جدا ويزيد
موقفها تواضعا هو وجود اطراف خارجيه تدعم
هذا الطرف هذا الطرف او ذلك الطرف ولا
تعير لمصادر القلق الامريكيه اي اهتمام
على ما يبدو لكن يعني الى اي مدى يمكن ما
الذي يمكن ان يؤثر في الموقف الامريكي
يعني هل هل هل
الحلفاء الاقليميون كاس اسرائيل كاميرات
لهم تاثير في هذا الموقف الذي يعترف بوجود
سلاح للدعم السريع من من فاجنر المصنفه
مجموعه ارهابيه عند الامريكان ومع ذلك ما
زال عند موقفه المحايد
حتى الان هناك اعتبارات ربما لا ندركها
جمله على الاداره الامريكيه مواقفها
الدبلوماسيه
ربما الان غياب الدبلوماسيين على الارض
وغياب تواصل الانساني مباشر مع الاطراف
المختلفه في السودان ترك لورش مواقف
محدوده وامكانيه
المناوره محدوده للغايه وبالتالي تحاول ان
تحافظ على ولد الطرفين الى اقصى حد ممكن
على الاقل
ربما اهداف انسانيه وقت اطلاق النار
لفترات اطول يمكن من اجل
توفير المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيين
والتكرار في كل مناسبه بانها ما زالت
مصممه على دعم ما تسميه التطلعات
الديمقراطيه للشعب السوداني دون ان تكشف
النقاب عن اي اجراءات ستت خذها عمليه انه
على الارض من اجل تفسير وترجمه ذلك الدعم
لتلك التطلعات اشكرك شكرا جزيلا محمد
العلمي مراسله من واشنطن